[Musica]
sono nato con un sogno un sogno Talmente
potente che alla fine è diventato il
motore della mia vita no e la parola
motore potenza non le ho utilizzate a
caso perché il sogno era quello di
diventare pilota automobilistico e se
Pensate ai bambini non so i bambini di
solito hanno i sogni più disparati ci
sono i bambini che sognano di andare su
Marte quelli che sognano di riportare in
vita i dinosauri c'è chi sogna di
diventare Harry Potter e tutto sommato
Il mio era un sogno abbastanza terra
terra no Insomma tutti abituati a vedere
le gare di auto C'è solo un piccolo
problema che molti non sanno che per
diventare piloti automobilistici servono
un sacco di soldi questa è una stima ho
preso Ad esempio la Formula 1 quella che
è un po' Tutti conoscono per arrivare
anche solo ad approcciarsi alla Formula
1 questa è l'investimento che bisogna
fare è la domanda Chi ce li deve mettere
quei soldi di solito sono mamma e papà
nel mio caso ovviamente mamma e papà
potessero mettere neanche lontanamente
un milionesimo di quei soldi e quindi
quel sogno per me era impossibile sin
dall'inizio
O almeno questo è quello che mi dicevano
perché
Questo sono io oggi mentre festeggio Una
delle mie prime vittorie e il mio
mestiere oggi è quello di fare il pilota
automobilistico e corrono il campionato
europeo nascar
Tra l'altro piccola aneddoto prima mi
hanno presentato come Alberto Fontana
quello il mio nome dell'anagrafe quasi
nessuno lo sa perché tutti mi conoscono
come nascano è una domanda che mi hanno
fatto anche prima di venire qui eh Ma
scusa ma nasca Perché corri con le
nascar in realtà non c'entra
assolutamente niente è una pura
coincidenza e per spiegarvi il perché
del mio nome vi faccio vedere questa
foto di quando avevo 16 anni
di quell'epoca non ho foto di profilo e
penso che porterà possiate iniziare a
intuire il perché se noi zoommiamo
Notiamo qualcosa di importante non su
quel volto praticamente non so come sia
possibile geneticamente ma ma quando ero
piccolo il mio naso era già grande come
adesso no io sono cresciuto intorno al
naso e quando sono andato a giocare a
calcio la prima volta ero praticamente
un naso con le gambe e i guantoni da
portiere il mio allenatore che era
siciliano e in siciliano nasca vuol dire
naso mi guarda non mi chiede neanche il
nome e mi dice Minchia che nasca che
c'hai da oggi tu ti chiami nasca
Ma al di là del nome Probabilmente
qualcuno si starà chiedendo Ok come ho
fatto analizzare quel sogno impossibile
il come nel dettaglio l'ho già spiegato
in un altro tedesco che ho fatto qualche
anno fa Quindi se volete potete poi
andare a curiosare vi farò un brevissimo
riassunto perché da lì voglio poi
raccontarvi di due cose che mi hanno
permesso realmente di realizzare quel
sogno Questo sono io sempre a 16 anni
quando ho capito che da grande volevo
fare il pilota e non sapendo come fare
soprattutto non avendo minimamente
neanche lontanamente il budget a
disposizione ho detto Ok quando non sai
cosa Come fare qualcosa inizia a fare
qualcosa che perlomeno ci assomiglia
così ho preso un volante per computer
scaricato videogame di auto e ha
iniziato a giocare videogames di auto
e l'idea era quella che un team un
giorno mi avrebbe notato avrebbe visto
il mio talento avrebbe detto wow Ti
prendiamo come pilota reale Ovviamente
non è successo niente di tutto ciò E
allora cosa ho fatto ho detto sai che
c'è per fare il pilota servono un sacco
di soldi ho visto che zackerberg si è
messo lì nel computer in 4-4-8 ha fatto
un'azienda da 50 miliardi di dollari lo
faccio anch'io Mi sono laureato in
ingegneria informatica e ovviamente è
finita lì i soldi non li ho fatti però
continuate a provarci e guardate un po'
qualche anno dopo è uscito fuori un
talent show per aspiranti piloti di
quelli tipo X Factor sapete quei
programmi lì in televisione ho detto wow
partecipo
Pensate un po' l'esperienza acquisita
sui simulatori di guida mi ha fatto
vincere il primo premio
come premio mi hanno fatto fare una
stagione da pilota quindi ho potuto
toccare con un dito quel sogno dopo che
io ribaltato due macchine e mi hanno
detto Arrivederci e grazie alla sua
stagione finisce qua e quindi poi non
sono diventato un pilota Ma io ero
testardo e ho detto sapete che c'è Se
non posso fare il pilota iniziamo a
lavorare in quel mondo qualcosa
succederà e dato che di passione facevo
i video ho detto sai che c'è vado a
vendere i video in pista i piloti e
questo è quello che facevo
in tutto questo sono passati 8 anni e io
ancora il pilota non lo facevo Sapete
cosa ho fatto quindi
ho fatto qualcosa di diverso Cioè mi
sono detto vado a fare un corso di
teatro
te vuoi fare il pilota e vai a fare un
corso di teatro
Che cosa c'entra perché
il motivo dietro questa scelta è il
seguente Ora penso che tutti voi
conosciate No questo giochino che si
faceva da bambini ma anche da adulti ci
sono i puntini li devi collegare tutti e
prima e a un certo punto quando finisci
viene fuori il disegno
Ma se io vi faccio vedere un foglio del
genere che disegno viene fuori da tre
puntini niente siete d'accordo ma se
invece il foglio è questo Io sono
convinto che tra di voi molte persone
faranno disegni diversi
I puntini sono le competenze che uno
acquisisce nel corso della vita quando
nasce un foglio completamente bianco e
ogni cosa che impari è un nuovo puntino
che aggiungi nel foglio della tua vita e
io quel giorno Ne ho aggiunto due teatro
e comunicazione
il tempo però passava e nel frattempo
siamo arrivati a novembre 2016 11 anni
dal giorno in cui ho deciso che avrei
fatto il pilota
di lavoro facevo ancora i video di
puntini ne avevo messi tanti ma il
disegno ancora non veniva fuori e sapete
che cos'è che ha fatto venir fuori quel
disegno è stato un gesto semplicissimo
da che ero abituato a tenere in mano la
telecamera in quel modo per riprendere
gli altri un giorno ho preso quella
telecamera e l'ho girata di 180 gradi e
ho iniziato a riprendere me stesso
mentre parlavo degli altri e del
Motorsport
quel giorno feci un video che pubblicai
su Facebook quel video divenne virale è
in due giorni fece 200.000
visualizzazioni avevo passato anni a
pubblicare video degli altri che non
funzionavano finché non ho pubblicato un
video di me stesso che incredibilmente
ha funzionato perché quel giorno capito
che c'erano tante persone che volevano
ascoltare qualcuno che raccontasse di
motori e in qualche anno sono arrivato
ad avere 860 mila iscritti sul mio
canale YouTube e Pensate un po' quei
puntini che possiamo vedere come le
stelle nel cielo in cui Un giorno
qualcuno si è messo lì le hanno insieme
detto wow se unisci quelle lì viene
fuori un carro Ecco se voi cambiate
sistema solare quel carro non c'è più
verrà fuori un'altra costellazione
perché cambi prospettiva
e io semplicemente cambiando prospettiva
e girando quella telecamera di 180 gradi
Ecco che è venuto fuori il disegno con
gli sponsor che ho trovato grazie al
canale YouTube e alla visibilità sono
diventato un pilota di auto
professionista
Ma c'è dell'altro che vi voglio dire
Ovvero Quanti di voi giocano ai
videogiochi alzate la mano dai non siete
timidi Ok un bel po' di gente ora Questo
gioco è GTA penso che voi lo conosciate
non so se lo sapete ma in GTA puoi
giocare in due modalità puoi giocare in
modalità prima persona o puoi giocare in
modalità terza persona quindi con la
telecamera che ti segue da dietro e la
fregatura della vita che purtroppo tutti
dobbiamo giocare in questa modalità qua
non penso che nessuno di noi abbia una
telecamera dietro che ci segue ci
vediamo da fuori no Tutti quanti vediamo
in prima persona
E che cosa succede succede che nel
momento in cui io ho iniziato a
riprendere me stesso
di colpo ho iniziato a vedere il mondo
così perché per la prima volta mi vedevo
da fuori e per la prima volta mi vedevo
Come mi vedono gli altri che qualcosa
che nessuno di noi è abituato a fare e
quindi ho iniziato a lavorare su me
stesso ho iniziato a rendermi conto di
alcuni gesti di alcune espressioni di
alcuni modi che avevo di fare e di
parlare perché qualcosa che non siamo
abituati a fare perché guardarci allo
specchio la mattina per quei 30 secondi
in cui cerchi di metterti dritto col
busto di sorridere di pettinarti e poi
esci fuori e fai tutto il contrario e
non siamo abituati a vederci da fuori e
io statisticamente sono sicuro che qui
dentro la maggior parte di voi non
faccio di lavoro l'attore il
presentatore il creatore di contenuti e
quindi non sia abituato a vedersi da
fuori
ma sono convinto Anzi sono sicuro al
100% ed è un dato matematico che il 100%
di voi Anzi delle persone al mondo si
relaziona con altre persone già solo per
essere entrati qui dentro e aver preso
l'accredito vi siete relazionati con
qualcun altro e quindi vi faccio una
domanda Cioè
ti sei mai chiesto come ti vedono gli
altri
da questo viaggio incredibile in cui ho
imparato tantissime cose che non posso
raccontarvi perché alla fine per
raccontare una vita ci vuole una vita
intera vi voglio raccontare due cose che
sono le due cose che ho imparato
La prima è quella che mi ha permesso per
la prima volta di vedere la soluzione a
quel problema di vedere come riuscire a
diventare pilota perché io ho messo
tutti i puntini su quel foglio ma ancora
non riuscivo a vedere il disegno ero
bloccato E quel disegno sono riuscito a
vederlo nel momento in cui ho cambiato
prospettiva nel momento in cui ho
iniziato a vedere le cose da un punto di
vista diverso anziché guardare dentro la
telecamera ho iniziato a guardare dentro
l'obiettivo e quindi se vi trovate in
una situazione della vostra vita in cui
non sapete come andare avanti Non vedete
una soluzione a quello che può essere un
problema o può essere un traguardo da
raggiungere Guardatelo da un altro punto
di vista se siete un venditore per un
giorno Fate il cliente se siete un
pizzaiolo per un giorno sedetevi al
tavolo a mangiare la pizza
scoprirete che il mondo da un altro
punto di vista è totalmente diverso
e la seconda cosa che ho imparato è
questa voglio che sia un gioco per chi
mi sta ascoltando È quello di giocare a
guardarsi da fuori
mettete una telecamera lì durante la
vostra giornata qualunque cosa siate
facendo che state parlando con qualcuno
che siate una riunione che siate andando
a fare la spesa e riprendetevi e
dimenticatevi a un certo punto di quella
telecamera
potrete finalmente guardarvi da fuori e
ascoltarvi e vi garantisco che
all'inizio è imbarazzante per tutti lo
so perché quando ho mandato un messaggio
audio su WhatsApp e poi le ha ascoltato
dice no vi prego Non ditemi che quella è
la mia voce Sì è solo questione di
abitudine per noi inizierete a guardarvi
da fuori e scoprirete delle cose che non
sapevate su voi stessi ma che tutto il
resto del mondo sapeva e che molto
spesso magari non ci dice o per paura di
farci del male o per timidezza o perché
semplicemente non gli importa niente di
noi e allora iniziate a guardarle voi
stessi perché così davvero sarete in
grado di vedervi da fuori e di potervi
imparare crescere e migliorare
Grazie
[Applauso]